grayscale just won their lawsuit against
the SEC here's everything you need to
know now first let's start with
grayscale grayscale launched a Bitcoin
trust years ago almost a decade and
since then they have become the largest
Bitcoin Fund in the world people all
around the world that wanted Bitcoin
exposure but didn't want to go buy it
through the spot Market could go on to
one of the exchanges and they could buy
the Bitcoin trust but it's a trust it is
not a true ETF the reason why is because
historically the SEC in the United
States has not approved a Bitcoin spot
ETF and so the trust was kind of a
workaround it was a way for you to buy a
public ticker and get exposure to
bitcoin without actually having
grayscale go to the SEC and get that
approval now in recent years what we've
seen is that that fund became very very
large over 40 billion dollars at one
point sat inside that Bitcoin Trust of
course grayscale wants to convert it to
a Bitcoin spot ETF and so they went
ahead and they applied converting a
trust to an ETF it's happened before
there's a process and the SEC he's got
to approve it but the SEC denied
grayscale's ability to go ahead and
convert from a Bitcoin trust into a
Bitcoin spot ETF around the same time
the SEC also approved multiple
futures-based Bitcoin ETFs so they
weren't spot ETS but they were Futures
based ETFs grayscale obviously was upset
by this they wanted to be the first to
get that Bitcoin spot ETF into the U.S
capital markets and so they decided in
what was somewhat of a controversial
move to sue the SEC now the SEC not only
do they not appreciate that grayscale
was disagreeing with them they also
probably didn't appreciate that
grayscale was suing them as well but now
this is part of the beauty of America is
that we have both sides the market
participant in grayscale and the SEC the
regulator go into court and they lay out
their arguments and in doing so what it
allows for is it allows for the
Democratic capitalistic process of
American courts the legal system to work
its self out and so now the SEC has been
told no grayscale is correct in this
specific situation this doesn't mean
that he's wrong all the time and it
doesn't mean that market participants
are right all the time but what it does
mean is that both parties went into
court of law and they went ahead and
they laid out all of their arguments and
the court decided that they are going to
support what grayscale is arguing and so
what that means is that the sac now has
to vacate the previous denial they have
to go back and have to re-evaluate the
application to convert from a Bitcoin
trust into a Bitcoin ETF now that does
not guarantee that the SEC is going to
all of a sudden wave a magic wand into
the grayscale it has the Bitcoin spot
ETF remember there's many other
applications that have been put forward
including kind of the elephant in the
room which is Blackrock that elephant in
the room of BlackRock is now competing
with grayscale it's somewhat of a foot
race to see who can be the first to get
a Bitcoin spot ETF approved now why does
it matter whether you're the first or
not well being the first is actually
really really really important because
what we've seen in the past take for
example the Futures based ETFs the
person who got out first or the group
that got out first they're the ones who
get most of the assets and so when you
look at grayscale versus BlackRock
BlackRock has better distribution
BlackRock has a bigger name and frankly
BlackRock has more trust in the
institutional world than grayscale or
any other crypto related asset manager
and so being able to get out into the
market first would be a huge Advantage
for what some see as the David versus
the Goliath but if all of a sudden the
SEC just said you know what green light
everyone gets approved at the same time
then it really is going to come down to
where do those assets flow well we have
seen over the years is that when an ETF
gets approved and is able to capture
assets if there's a early winner in that
category usually the upstarts are not
able to unseat who that winner is and so
getting out first into the market is
really really important especially with
an asset class like Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies where there seems to be
a bunch of pent-up demand people waiting
to allocate to the space but there is no
spot ETF and so literally being the
first pays off here now the reason why
it's important that the courts made this
decision is we're leaving the world of
opinions kind of hot takes on the
internet and we're now getting into the
courts and the courts are able to decide
what actually has to happen they can
enforce these rules and so by saying to
the SEC you have to vacate that denial
and go back and reevaluate the SEC still
retains the right to deny the conversion
of grayscale's Bitcoin trust into a spot
Bitcoin ETF for any other reason they
have a whole plethora of things that
they could bring up and say we are not
going to approve this but my guess is
that that's unlikely to happen right we
now have a court saying hey the reason
that you gave initially is not
sufficient enough you also have
BlackRock coming in with the application
you have people like Arc invest 21
shares you have bitwise uh Invesco the
list goes on and on and on and so my
guess is that what's going to happen
here is we're getting closer and closer
the odds have increased that a Bitcoin
spot ETF is going to get approved in the
United States there's a report on
Bloomberg today that says that actually
a a decision on the application for
BlackRock could happen as soon as this
week
um given the grayscale decision now all
of a sudden it kind of puts a a light
onto this and we're starting to see
people say okay are we actually at the
end are we at the point the Bitcoin spot
ETF is going to get approved I'm not
sure but it does feel like we are much
closer today than we were yesterday on
top of that there's a big question of
how many assets would actually flow into
a Bitcoin spot ETF some people think
that it could be a couple hundred
million dollars some people think it
could be tens of billions of dollars my
guess is that within the first 24 to 48
hours there would be at least one
billion dollars that would flow into the
Bitcoin spot ETF and then within the
first month to three months I wouldn't
be surprised if we saw over 10 billion
dollars flowing into that asset now why
is that important when you start to
think about one five ten billion dollars
some of these asset managers out here
have a trillion plus dollars it's not
that big but what it does show you is
when you look at the Bitcoin Market the
Bitcoin market cap is about half a
trillion dollars and so if you were to
go and get five billion dollars put into
a Bitcoin spot ETF that's one percent of
the total market cap of the asset and
then when you start to look at okay well
what happens when it gets to 10 billion
25 billion 50 billion a hundred billion
dollars if that's possible now you start
talking about anywhere between 10 to 20
percent of the total market cap now
obviously bitcoin's price is volatile
it'll move and as more money comes in
it'll probably push the price up given
that Bitcoin is a finite asset but it
does begin to speak to the fact that
there is going to be a catalyst now when
the Bitcoin spot ETF gets approved that
is a catalyst for the market and what
people have been saying is look the
Market's really illiquid seventy percent
of the Bitcoin in circulation hasn't
moved in over a year and so if you've
got all this illiquidity in the market
you need some sort of catalyst some sort
of increase in demand in order to
kick-start what is many people looking
at uh kind of a a potential increase in
price in the future and so maybe this
Bitcoin spot ETF is that Catalyst if you
have a Bitcoin spy ETF that gets
approved then within less than one year
you're gonna have the Bitcoin having
which means you're going to have a
supply shock this is a demand shock this
could be a rerun all over again of what
we saw in 2020 when we had kind of a
supply shock in the having and then we
had a demand shock with all the free
money that was dropping from the sky
getting put into the market I don't know
what's going to happen no one has a
crystal ball but again the decision
today that grayscale is going to Prevail
in this lawsuit against the SEC is
definitely moving us one step closer to
actually getting a Bitcoin spot ETF in
the United States BlackRock obviously
has got to be excited about this as well
because it's putting more pressure on
the situation in order to get someone
approved so that American investors can
now get access to that Bitcoin spot ETF
it's going to be really really
interesting to watch how this plays out
through the rest of this week and in the
coming months so please pay attention if
you enjoyed this video make sure that
you go ahead and you subscribe leave a
comment do all the things that people
say to do on YouTube I appreciate it I
hope this was valuable and I'll see you
guys in the next video